- And so, I never went to
school, anything like that.
Like I said, no brothers, no
sisters, no wife, no kids.
- [Interviewer] No parents?
- Huh?
- No parents, after your mom.
- No parents, no, I never
knew my father at all,
never saw him at all.
And I flew from Cleveland.
(breathes shakily)
I flew, Jacksonville, Florida,
from Jacksonville to Cleveland,
Ohio to see this man.
Where I was at the first time.
I flew back to Cleveland to see him.
(sniffles) Excuse me.
And my grandmother
called him on the phone.
And told him, said, "Your
only son is in town,
"do you want to see him?"
He wouldn't drive a mile
to come see me in his car.
I flew 3,000 miles to see him.
- [Interviewer] You came
from Florida to Cleveland.
- Yeah.
- And he wouldn't go a mile?
- He wouldn't get in his
car, not a mile, to see me.
He told me to bring me down there!
I said, "No, I'm not goin'."
So we talked on the phone, (sniffles)
and I told him, I said,
"You know I don't do drugs?"
He said, "That's a good thing."
I said, "I know it is."
I said, "You know, I don't do wild sex,
"and I ain't got no girls pregnant."
I said, "You know, I'm pretty
built, and I look good."
He said, "Well, that's all good.
"You gonna come down and see me?"
I said, "No, I'm not."
And it is all good, 'cause my
mother taught me to do that.
And I told 'im on the phone, I say,
"It was a woman, that taught
me how to be a man," you know?
I got some tissue, I got
some baby wipes here, too,
yeah.
- Okay.
- I said, "It was a woman who
taught me how to be a man.
"And everything I
learned about being a man
"was from a woman."
And he wouldn't come see me,
(sniffles)
and so, they had bought
me a round-trip ticket,
I got on the plane four days later,
and flew back to Jacksonville.
But I did see him once, right?
I remember seeing somebody,
but I was so young,
I couldn't recognize what he looked like.
You know?
But I remember seein' somebody once,
when I was very, very, young, you know?
But I never saw 'im after that no more.
- Saw somebody that you
thought was your dad?
- Well, I saw a guy, I
remember him, a black guy.
We was in a movie
theater, I remember that.
And I was very young.
He either worked there, or he owned it.
I think it was my dad, you know?
But my mom died so early, of cancer, so.
I was like 12 years old when she died.
But as far as the schooling goes,
we traveled a lot, because my grandmother
and my mother's fightin'
on who would raise me.
And so she had to run away with me.
And then by the time I got
maybe eight, nine, 10 years old,
they felt, my mother had cancer,
and wasn't able to take care o' me.
So they put me in a foster home,
I ran away from the foster home.
Miss Clayton, I took the
garbage out one morning,
she knew, she was a good lady.
Gimme a minute here, 'cause--
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I know.
- Sometime I get a little
emotional when I think.
But I'm good spirit, but I'm sayin'
sometime when I think about it.
'Cause she was a good woman,
but she knew I was gonna run,
when I went and took the
trash out one morning.
She say, "Baby, come on back."
And I looked at 'er,
and I took off runnin'.
- [Interviewer] Just in case.
- I just walked down the street.
I didn't run, I didn't, but
she knew I wasn't comin' back.
'Cause I was there one day,
and the first day I was there--
- [Interviewer] This is the foster home?
- Yeah.
The first day I was there,
I'm a fighter, right?
I never been a real coward, so,
the first day I was
there, one o' my brothers,
I had met him in there, my foster brother.
He got in a fight.
I walked around the corner,
about 10, 15 guys was on 'im.
Well, about three or
four of 'em was on him.
And I turned around, and I asked him,
I said, "Joshua," I say ...
he was a white boy, 'cause
it was a foster home, right?
And I walked around, asked Joshua, I said,
"What's wrong, Joshua, why
you standin' against the car
"and all three of these guys
standin' in front o' you?"
And when he looked at
me, he wouldn't speak.
And I stepped up, and
I said, "What's wrong?
"Shit, you can talk to me."
And then one of the dudes
turned around, he said,
"And what do you got to do with this?"
I said, "That's my brother."
"He's a white boy, you're black,"
I said, "We in a foster home
together, that's my brother."
He say, "Well, this man owe us money."
And I say, "For what?"
He said, "Because you gotta
pay to live on this street."
I said, "I just moved here,
I'm not payin' you shit."
And I got down.
And he said, "Well, we'll
drag you up against the car,"
and I told 'im, I say, "I'm your guy."
And when I went to fightin' these guys,
I was doin' pretty good with
the three of 'em, right?
Then, for a while I
had a whole city block.
People runnin' from
everywhere, women, and kids,
and he hit me in the head with bricks,
this was in Jacksonville, Florida.
And they was hittin' me
in the head with bricks,
and sticks, and when I
got home that evenin',
shirt tore all up, Joshua ran.
He went, but I didn't take it personally,
he ran, because he was
young, and I realized
he wasn't the type of guy I was, you know?
Everybody's not a fighter.
Some people are very brainy and smart.
Joshua was very smart, with
books, anything like that.
(sniffs) So he ran, and when I got home,
my shirt was tore up, and
my eyes looked swollen.
Nothin' that real life-threatenin',
but a little blood, and over here,
I think I had to get three, four stitches
in the head with some people
that hit me in the head
with bricks and shit.
And so Miss Clayton, she said,
"What happened to you?"
I said, "Aw, nothin'," I didn't tell 'er
I was savin' Joshua, I said, "Aw, nothin',
"I was just out there playin',
nothin' to worry about."
And she looked at my head, and said,
"Oh, your head's bleedin' so bad,
"we gonna take you to the hospital."
They put three, four stitches in there.
But the next mornin' when I woke up,
I couldn't live like that, you know?
So I took the garbage out,
and she knew I was gonna run.
And I ran, I walk away, and
she knew I wasn't comin' back.
And they put my face on
milk cartons and stuff,
talkin' about, "Have you seen this kid,"
and made it like I was from
a rich family or somethin',
they were lookin' for me, and I wasn't.
(laughs) They just
wanted to find me quick.
- [Interviewer] So, you
lost your mom at what age?
- About 12 years.
I never saw 'er again after I left.
I didn't, I think, once they
put me in a foster home,
they were runnin', lookin' for me so much.
I was raised, well, I stayed only with her
till I was about 12, 13 years old.
- [Interviewer] And she died of cancer?
- Cancer, uh-huh.
And so then they put me
in a, when they caught me,
they put me in like a group home,
called Trenton.
One was called Trenton, and
one was called Marianna.
It was for boys had done crime.
But I had never did no crime.
I was just, you know, runnin'
from foster homes and stuff.
- [Interviewer] Be careful with eating.
Just hold off--
- Oh, okay, I'm sorry, yeah.
And I was runnin' from
foster homes and stuff,
so I never really did no crime,
but they put me in there.
And I didn't know how to read or nothin'.
I didn't know how to read,
and then so I started,
you know, walkin' around
lookin' at store signs, and--
- [Interviewer] So, how
much schooling did you get?
- Oh, pretty, hardly none.
I think I went to kindergarten
for about two months,
and maybe elementary about a month.
I never really, I don't even remember.
- [Interviewer] You never saw high school.
- No, no, no, no.
- You never saw,
even grade school.
- No, no, no.
- [Interviewer] But you
taught yourself to read.
- Yeah, uh-huh.
I taught myself to read by walkin'
and lookin' at signs and stuff.
Just standin' there, just
wait, like FedEx, you know?
And I would figure it out.
And I would just figure it
out, I kept tryin' and tryin',
like Annie bean, Annie's Bean.
You know, I kept figurin' it out.
And I got messed over a
lot, I went to jail a lot,
for things, I mean, prison a lot,
'cause I couldn't read
contracts and stuff like that.
You know, like one time, I stole a radio.
I was just, wanted to get
somethin' to eat, you know?
I was in Oklahoma, and there
was a radio on the car seat.
I just reached and grabbed,
that's a small misdemeanor, right?
First time I'd ever been in trouble,
and they sent me to prison
for three years for that.
And then, I need to tell you something,
off the record, though,
when you're, off the camera.
- Okay.
- 'Cause that's kinda private.
And so, I kept goin' to jail,
and I was learnin' to read,
I was gettin' better,
but I kept goin' to jail.
Not because I was a hell of a lawbreaker,
but because I didn't have nobody to,
no lawyer, no money, no family or nothin'.
And I could tell, from the
way that the things I did,
all the stuff goin' on in the world,
I knew, I had the knowledge, and knew
that you were messin' me over.
It's just, I couldn't do nothin' about it.
'Cause I was so young,
and I didn't understand,
you know, a lot of things
back then, the courts.
So, I mean, that's not, that's just
the way life is sometime, you know?
You can't be bitter about
that when you grow up,
'cause, you know, I tell a
lotta people we never gonna live
in a problem-free world,
see what I'm sayin'?
There's always gonna be a problem.
To every problem there's a
solution, but to every solution,
there's another problem occurs, you know?
So, we have to learn to live with that.
And, yeah, I got raped one time.
I got, tried to rape me one
time, in Cleveland, Ohio.
He took me in the butt, and
tried to put a fork to my neck.
And I was young, and I
jumped out the window
with my underwear on, and
ran down the alleyway.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- I was about, shoot, I was
probably about 13 or 14 then.
Somewhere, I don't remember.
But I was very young, I
wasn't even 15 at that time.
So I know I was either 14 or younger.
And I tried to tell the police about it,
and they talked me out
of it, in Cleveland.
They said, "Well, you sure
"you wanna press charges on this guy?
"Go to court, and tell 'em all that stuff
"in the courtroom, and, you know?
"You maybe just oughta
let it go, you know."
I didn't want to, but I did,
'cause I was young, and they made me think
that I would be embarrassed
in the courtroom,
and I had to tell all this stuff.
So, I never reported it.
And then one time, I was in LA.
I was homeless, in Hollywood.
And out came one o' the
most beautiful girls
I had ever seen in my
life, her name was Mytelle.
She was a white girl, long blonde hair
all the way down to damn
near her kneecaps, her knees.
And she was standin' in front
of one o' the roughest part
of Hollywood's back then, it was rough.
And real nasty back then,
full o' gangbangers,
and full of rough guys, like, you know,
we had to be rougher than
the roughest back then.
'Cause this was like in
the '80s, early '80s.
And didn't nobody care.
But anyway, to make a long story short,
I had a friend, worked
for the police department,
and Mytelle wouldn't tell
me where she was from.
But she was very beautiful.
And I wanted, she liked me, and I wanted,
when we stayed together and she
wanted to be with me, right?
And I wanted to, but I thought,
"Got to find out who I'm
sleepin' with, you know?"
I said, "I can't do that till I find out
"who this girl is," you
know, she had no ID.
So I gave her picture
to a buddy o' mine at the police station.
He came back with a poster,
and she was facin' this way,
and that way, with all these
things in front of her.
And I thought, "God damn it,
"this beautiful woman a criminal?"
Well, he said she wasn't.
So, on the bottom o' the
poster, said "call this number."
I called the number
and it was her parents.
And I said, "You have a
daughter named Mytelle?"
He said, "Yes, we lookin' for her,
"she's very young, and
she ran away from home."
I said, "Well, she's out here
in Los Angeles, California."
Nah, I said, "She's out here in a suburb
"of Los Angeles, California,
called Hollywood."
He said, "Yes, yes," he
said, "We want her home!"
I said, "Okay.
"I'm gonna put her on a bus,
"and send her back to your home.
"You be at the bus
station to pick her up."
He said, "No, no, no,
no, you can't do that,
"she'll jump off the bus!"
I said, "And so what
do you want me to do?"
He said, "We'll pay you,
bring her back out here."
She had to go to Kenosha, Wisconsin.
One of the suburbs, I mean, a city,
right off the border of Illinois.
It's supposed to be the
last little city in--
- [Interviewer] Yep, I know Kenosha.
- Yeah, see, I had to take
her to Kenosha, Wisconsin.
But he said, "Bring 'er back!"
And I was like, I said, "You want me?"
(laughs) That's all I
said, I said, "You want me,
"to leave Los Angeles right now,
"come all the way out to Chicago,
"to bring your daughter home?"
I said, "That ain't gonna happen, sir.
"I just can't pull up like that,
"and just leave Los Angeles like that."
He say, "Well, would
$2,000 make you do that?"
(laughs) I said, "Come again?"
He say, "I'll pay you two grand,
"you bring my daughter home."
And so I said, "Okay,
"I guess I'm goin' on a trip!" (giggles)
And I jumped on the Greyhound,
and we rode all the way the Greyhound.
She cried, and didn't wanna go back,
wanted to stay, and I said, "I can't.
"It's too rough out there, you know,
"I have no way of takin' care o' you,
"and, you know, it's too dangerous,
"everybody's killin' everybody,
"this is not the place for you right now."
And so, she cried, I got her
to the Chicago bus station.
I took her to Chicago,
I didn't actually go
to Kenosha, Wisconsin,
they met us in Chicago.
And so, when they got in Chicago,
her parents, they looked at me like,
"Boy, (chuckles) this a
rough-lookin dude here!"
'Cause I mean, I was dressed
nice, had my jeans on,
and back at this time I had
a pair of steel-toe boots,
the kind with the, had the
overlap over, the steel over it?
And then, you know, I'm wearin' shorts
when I come out, not pants.
And it's cold out there!
But it was hot in Los Angeles.
So I went, and see all my
veins stickin' out o' my legs,
and, you know, I got
a jacket, a hoodie on,
but I got a hoodie on with a zip-down.
I didn't have a necklace at the time.
But I had a hoodie on, and
I was really bigger then,
you know, I'm just kinda cut now.
But I had a little size then.
And so they looked at me like,
"Boy, this dude look rough."
So, I walked up to 'er, and
they saw Mytelle walk into us.
And I said, "Yes, this is your daughter.
"Nobody have ever touched
'er, and she's back home."
And she cried, she wanted to stay with me,
cried in that Chicago bus station.
And I said, "Damn, boy, that bus ride,
"I gotta take a long bus ride back."
And they said, "No, we're
gonna get you a motel
"for a couple days, and
we gonna get your $2,000,
"but we'll get you on Amtrak."
I said, "Well, how you gonna do all that?
"I'm not gonna stay around with y'all.
"And I'm not goin' out to your house.
"Never go to a house I
ain't never been to before
"with people I don't know," you know?
And he said, "No, we'll get you a motel,
"we'll just go home, we gonna
make sure you get the room,
"and we're gonna get your money,
"get you enough money to
eat on, and stuff like that,
"and we gonna get you enough
money to buy you a ticket.
"If you don't feel that relaxed, you know,
"bein' among the people you don't know,"
he said, "I understand, you know."
And he said, "I'm glad
you brought my daughter."
They took care of all that.
So I got on the Amtrak,
the first time I ever rode a Amtrak train.
And I got on the Amtrak, came back to Los,
and they had these big-ass windows.
And you can drink on the Amtrak.
And goin' on the Amtrak,
took us through Colorado.
And what I did not know is that
all the time, way up in
the Colorado mountains,
I'd never saw a snow-white buck.
But I saw a snow-white
buck with a pink nose!
And I said, "How'd that happen?"
He say, "We don't get much sun
"up here, 'cause it gets too cold.
"And the bucks don't get no"--
- Yeah, they're albino.
- Don't get that much sun.
I say, "But snow-white?
"They're not half-brown!" (laughs)
I said, "You get some sun!"
- [Interviewer] Yeah, there's
white deer all over.
- They're snow-white.
Yeah, he said, "They're bucks."
And all that time, oh,
one thing I forgot--
- Tell me about the girl.
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Did you ever
hear from the girl again?
- No, I never did hear
from her again, uh-uh.
I never did hear from Mytelle no more.
Which was a good thing,
because I could tell
when I talked to her, she's not
ready for this kind of life,
and I don't know if she would ever be.
Mytelle was very
intelligent, and very smart.
But she's like a girl that
would be in a college,
or a good job, she's not street smart.
And out here, they would've
probably raped her,
gave her AIDS, and she'd have
been pregnant anytime soon,
and whatever career she had on her mind
woulda been messed up, you know?
But now, one thing I forgot to tell you
when I was takin' her back.
On the way down, me and
Mytelle got on the right bus,
'cause there was two Greyhound
buses, they got too full.
The first one, ahead of us,
ran off the side of a cliff
and killed everybody on the bus.
- [Interviewer] Oh, you're kidding.
- No, the one in front, it went over.
We got on the second bus.
- Wow.
- If we'd've been on the
first bus, we woulda died.
'Cause it was snowy, and icy
road, or somethin' like that,
and one o' them Greyhound
buses ran off the side
o' the thing.
- Oh, jeez.
- Some kinda ravine.
I didn't see, but it landed
on some kinda steep edge.
And from what I heard from what they said
about the bus, everybody on the bus died.
Everybody on that first
Greyhound got killed.
And then, so, once I got back to LA,
you know, I got back in the street.
All this time, I was always
homeless with no family,
when I'm goin' through this, so.
I don't know how I got
into all these experiences,
but, and I lived in
many different cultures.
I was homeless in, New York,
where it's very cold there.
I was homeless in
Cleveland, and I made my way
to Seattle, Washington,
I was homeless there.
- [Interviewer] And you're
entirely self-taught.
- Yeah, and so--
- [Interviewer] No schooling.
- No schoolin', uh-uh.
Just among, you know, learning
from people, you know.
Lookin at they behavior,
and the way they do things,
and just payin' attention to life,
but no schoolin', no tutorin',
no teachin' or nothin' like--
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- Uh, 53, now, I just turned--
- Oh, 53.
- I had a birthday two weeks
ago, three weeks ago, yeah.
And so, no, no schoolin', no tutorin'.
And, matter of fact, as I learnt,
a lot o' people out here say,
"How did you learn all that?
"To hear you speak, you know,
"I listen to the things you say,"
and a lotta the guys on the street
try to get me to teach them!
And I say, "Do you think
I can teach you anything?"
He say, "Yeah, I hear
you talk, and," I say,
"Do you know I don't have
one day of school in myself?
"How I'm gonna teach you?"
He said, "Well, just teach,"
they were lookin' at me,
and said, "Well just teach us
"what you talkin' about right there.
"We ain't askin' you to
give us no education!
"We just wanna learn some
o' the stuff you know."
I said, "Okay, I'll do the best I can."
And so I did that, you
know, I would help guys.
Even the guys around here now,
even the young dude
when they hear me talk.
Some of 'em be ready to beat me up,
and then, (laughs) this
one big guy, always
look and me and say, "I keep forgettin'
"to beat that little mother," he say,
"but he always right, man, you know?"
He say, "We wanna kick his ass,
"he talk too much, but he always right."
- [Interviewer] So, you
had 12 years with your mom.
- Yeah.
- How was your relationship
with your mom?
- Me and my mom, we got along real good
while she was livin', but she was so sick
all the time, with cancer, you know.
That's another reason
I didn't go to school,
I had to take care o'
her, I had to stay home
and take care o' her.
- Oh.
- Because she was in the
hospital for a long time,
for a while, but we couldn't
afford the hospital bill.
So now, I had to stay
home and take care o' her.
- [Interviewer] You're her only child?
- Yeah.
Until they took me to
put me in a foster home.
And once they took me there,
I never got to see 'er again.
She died, before I'd ever
see her again, you know.
And then, I went to prison,
up here in California for a while.
And what happened, the way
I found out about her again,
I'd never met none o' her
sisters or cousins, right?
But they had a missing
person report out on me,
my mom's only child, right?
And when I got outta prison here,
the cops at one o' the
stations told me, he said,
"You know you got a missing
person report out on you?"
I said, "I have no family to be missin'."
He said, "Somebody out
there lookin' for you,
"and they from Cleveland, Ohio.
"Now, I don't know if
you got family or not,
"but there's a missing person,
"somebody there's lookin' for you."
So I said, "All right."
And he gave me a number,
and I called the number.
And this woman get on the phone,
she said, "I'm your aunt Antoinette.
"We looked for you for years,
my sister's only child."
She said, "We looked for you for years."
(sniffles) "And we couldn't find you."
And I said, "Where's my mother?"
She said, "Your mother died."
And I flew to Cleveland, for a third time.
And then I found out she
wasn't buried in Cleveland,
so I had to go to Georgia,
where her father was.
And I met my grandfather,
for the first time.
I only stayed about a week. (sniffles)
And I said, "What
cemetery my mother buried,
"I wanna go see the grave." (sniffs)
And they buried her way out in the woods.
'Cause they didn't have money
to put 'er in the good cemetery.
"It's by the tree that
grows on her grave,"
we had to find it.
We had to dig through
the trees, the grave.
And I thought, "This what
you do to your daughter?"
(sniffs) And I told my auntie, I said,
"This what you do to y'all sister.
"You bury 'er way out there
where nobody see 'er."
The trees. (whimpers)
They grew all over.
And so, I left. (sniffles)
After I saw my mother's grave,
and the way they treated their sister,
and his daughter, I never
wanna see 'em no more.
I left, and I never went back.
It was just a hard life. (sniffs)
For her.
I didn't care so much about myself.
She was always sick, and
she was a good woman.
(sniffs) It was a hard life for 'er.
(blowing nose) Excuse me.
And I'm not a very big guy now, so.
I'm out here being the only
child, and a very small guy.
And no schoolin', nobody to teach me,
I had to learn the best way I could.
And I start pickin' up old things.
And I told myself, "Your
mother's in her grave,
"and your grandmother gone, too,
"so you not gonna grow up ignorant.
"And you not gonna grow
up not havin' a life.
"And you gonna teach yourself,
"and you gonna do whatever you can.
"And you gonna work hard,
because you will not be a loser.
"You might be po'. (sniffs)
"But you're not gonna be a loser."
And I fought hard, and
this is where it land me.
And I'm not mad at life.
I'm happy, and just, some o' the things
that I think about, in the past,
it makes me a little emotional.
But I've had a good life.
And I'm proud o' my life, and,
I never really was materialistic anyway.
I never had a driver
license or phone, a house.
I never had, I haven't
touched a woman in 14 years.
I'm not gay, I'm disease-free,
I never had no tattoos, no pierced ears,
or any o' that, you know?
- [Interviewer] And I
see you all the time,
I've seen you hundreds of
times, you're always happy.
- Yeah, I'm always happy--
- [Interviewer] You're
always in a good mood.
- Yeah, because, (grunts) excuse me.
Bein' in a bad mood ain't gonna do nothin'
but make it worse, and it's not the world,
I don't feel like it's
the world's problem.
- [Interviewer] But you're honest.
- Yeah.
- You're hard-working.
- Right.
- You're a good guy,
you help out people that need help.
- Yes, I do.
Anytime.
(laughing) I gave about, shoot,
almost half a pack o'
cigarettes to one everybody,
got no money, "Can I
get one, can I get one?"
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you're like
the mayor of Skid Row down here.
- Yeah, pretty much.
Me and a other guy, you know, me and him,
we a different type o' characters,
but, you know, live the
same, he help people, too.
But you know, our entire
personalities a little different.
But other than that, you
know, we about the same.
So, that's it right
there for me right now.
- Excellent.
- I know you got things to do,
and you probably got
other people comin' in,
so we gonna cut it short.
And to the world, thank you,
and whatever you see on
this, I hope you enjoy.
(Interviewer laughing)
It's only for your
entertainment, and for your listening.
So, thank y'all out there,
and have a good life.
- [Interviewer] All right, Cigarette Man.
- [Cigarette Man] (laughs) All right.
(sighs)
- That was great.
So that was a three-part video.
(Cigarette Man laughs)
I was taking
your two-hour talk, and I turned it--
- Oh, I'm sorry!
- No, no, no, no, no, no!
This was the best one!
- Oh, okay--
- It's all good.
Everything you share
is always interesting.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you're
such a great speaker.
- [Cigarette Man] Well,
(laughs), you know,
there's a lot o' good people in the world.